but not if your enemies are still alive
have a lot of time on their hands to
edit Wikipedia
so Elon Musk was at the Tesla Factory in
Austin Texas uh with Benjamin Netanyahu
and they gave a press conference after
and they talked about a whole bunch of
stuff related to Ai and algorithms and
just all of the stuff uh and Elon had a
good line on truth and how we see truth
from a historical perspective
you know like there's an adult saying
like history is written by the by The
Victors it's like well yes but not if
your enemies are still alive have a lot
of time on their hands to edit Wikipedia
who can harness the most editors yeah I
mean you know the the whoever the losers
just got a lot of time on their hands
and uh you know
what do they do edit Wikipedia
and literally there's something there
and he is right literally so the the
general concept right history is written
by the winners why do the good guys
always seem to win it's because they're
the survivors then can write the history
we all like to think that we have like
an honest assessment of history and I
think from an American perspective we
have a pretty good one right we have a
pretty good honest assessment of what
our history has been and also that it
helps also that our history in America
is only 250 some odd years old almost
250.
um
so history is written but but how this
changes then is what's happening in our
modern world
with deep fakes with AI with Wikipedia
constantly being edited and then someone
goes oh I like David but I'm going to
check his Wikipedia page and you don't
know what nonsense they'd put on there
trust me there's nonsense on there like
it's just it's the editors as Netanyahu
says history will be who can never mind
the most editors you get editors you get
activists all of these things and one
day we will never know what's true so we
have a we have a truth war on two fronts
we have the truth and then two fronts
coming after it we've the people who
will lie constantly for political
reasons to attain power whatever it
might be and then we also have the
machines and the algorithms who will
feed those lies and all of those things
it's that versus the truth